c'est une journée complètement folle qui
vient de se dérouler ici au palais de
justice de besançon elle a commencé à 9h
ce matin par l'audition des parents
d'alexia d'aval ainsi que de leur fille
stéphanie et du mari de cette dernière
grégory gay la famille d'alexia était
convoqué par le juge d'instruction une
semaine jour pour jour après l'audition
du principal suspect dans la sphère le
mari de la victime janata navale puis
est venu le coup de théâtre il
semblerait que johnattan d'aval soit
revenu la semaine dernière sur ces abus
comme nous l'a confirmé l'un de ses
conseils maître randall schwerdorffer on
dirait simplement qu'une seule chose
c'est que en l'état à ce jour du matin
d'aval conteste être l'auteur des faits
d'homicide peu qu'on lui reproche sur la
personne d'élections johnattan d'aval
serait même allé plus loin il portera
ses accusations sur son beau frère
grégory y ait un vote quant au passage
un pacte de la famille pour garder le
secret stratégie de défense ou véritable
révélation il appartient désormais à
l'instruction de faire toute la lumière
sur cette affaire notamment au vu des
éléments concrets du dossier qui a
véritablement tué alexia qui était au
couvent qui a transporté le corps qui a
procédé à la tentative de crémation m
florent le conseil a des parents d'alex
est donc du beau frère mise en cause n'a
pas commenté ce rebondissement se
contentant simplement de préciser que
son client est sous le choc et nie
formellement être l'auteur du meurtre de
sa belle soeur